you have a man who rolls you blunts yes
yes is that right yeah what do you mean
a man who rose gage the look on
someone's face with it seems like water
blood and if they do guy who
specifically hired by you
that's his jo be his occupation on his
resume say what do you do I'm a blunt
arrow is that what he is - you know
freebie what is it what kind of income
can a guy make rolling joy you know it's
almost like a sommelier how do you look
figure out a salary for this guy that's
somewhere between 40 and 50 thousand
dollars a year really it's tough that is
[ __ ] awesome and he rolls the but he
takes the blunts from the box rolls them
into weed and puts them back in the box
oh I've spent hours smoking weed with
Snoop and there's been like 40 minutes
rubs like I'm just watching this guy and
I'm just gonna see what is going on here
she says if somebody smokes a lot of
weed it's [ __ ] fast I'm jealous of I
mean that is almost that's genius it is
say you know this is something I love I
got a guy here who can roll yeah I'm
[ __ ] giving him a job from 50 grand a
year it would probably honestly the
amount of time I spent rolling joints it
might be worth my while financially to
hire some
[Laughter]